i didn't know i just had basically seven
shots of espresso and i thought it
wasn't like that bad and then brandon
was like you're gonna die and then i was
like dude i might die yeah yeah i'm
jealous of the being placebo yeah
because like i'll take champion this
ain't working
[Music]
watching all that chapelle loves our own
soda
[Laughter]
i mean that tattoo begs the difference
and i think that's a gang affiliate i
just got it though so if i was in a game
before i should have got that way back
in the day true but you've changed your
life a lot you want it you want to keep
it that's why i want to get a tattoo
yeah let me do it now now i can really
do it now you just have to really
embrace the game
straight program shouts out to asian
gangs yeah shout outs out there i mean i
guess so i don't know
i'm not going to talk smack on them
because they jumped me big time i know
yeah all respectively
multiple times
think about jumping a person bro you
can't even get any hits in dude
like the seventh dude over there what
are you gonna do
who who you who you hitting your friend
you guys don't think about that i know
that all the time when people jump
people of course they have to hit each
other everyone's trying to get on the
one guy you're hitting your friend yeah
yeah you're happy yeah you're not
hitting
it's like the guy that that [ __ ] that
got jumped for taking the death row
chain
and eventually uh killed tupac sugar no
no not suge knight
you guys don't know you know i remember
the story you know they know who killed
tupac right
i don't know that his name was [ __ ]
baby lane he was a [ __ ]
he was a guy they jumped in the
it was the last vegas police department
let's get that straight right now
everyone has all these conspiracies
to to tupac said that meanwhile
everybody knows who killed him
look at maybe like the guy on the right
the guy on the left the guy on the right
that's the guy they jumped he's
foreshadowing him right now he's like
that's the guy they jumped
in the uh what do you call it at the mgm
grand uh oh in the the casino in vegas
you know what i'm talking about yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the casino
infamous elevator he got off the
elevator there yeah
dude
speaking of hip-hop
and then we'll get into [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah but i i was thinking about it they
took off uh
the first chronic album and doggy style
after streaming yeah why
because i i think uh he bought his own
rights to it so so snoop dogg bought
death row owns death row records so i
wonder if they're trying to negotiate to
where they own the rights to those two
records
because when doc because when they left
suge was like i'm keeping all y'all [ __ ]
so i was watching snoop dogg on uh drink
champs
it might have been folsom that i was
watching
but he said uh he was like if i can sell
the likeness to my song to a movie why
can't i sell it as an nft and now you
own
snoop doggy dog and you can use that
whenever you want from buying the nft
also suge knight owns the name snoop
doggy dog yeah whoa that's why he's been
going by that's why it's snoop that's
why you haven't heard him go by snoop
dogg dog in years
because he just goes by snoop dogg
because suge owns the name snoop doggy
dog wow isn't that crazy
hey [ __ ] bully
that's an understatement
rolled over someone with his suv i know
we saw we all saw the video too right
how crazy is that video it's crazy it's
one of those things i regretted watching
it sucks yeah i know i was like why did
i watch this i don't want this [ __ ]
that's why i don't want to watch that
boxer no one breaks yeah yeah don't
bring up the boxer i don't want to now
that you know he passed away that yeah
yeah you guys ever see beheadings that's
the one thing i regret watching but i
thought i had to watch it because it was
a real thing
the first guy that died they did it with
a [ __ ] butter knife
[Music]
but also i don't think
i don't know
you would think you chen have you have
your you know man you have your issues
with videos
all the time you're like i don't know i
don't trust that video oh yeah yeah but
i mean he oh no no you're not beheading
people we never saw him
he's not that far
hey man why are you bringing up my old
[ __ ]
don't fuel the rumors man no but i mean
when the guy was never found again he
was in was it afghanistan or iraq yeah
yeah just that that video
it didn't look real because of how easy
it was for them to do it but then i'm
like thinking now every time they'd
behead people because it's like that
quick bones and [ __ ] yeah it's what the
[ __ ]
it's so gross man yeah that's why
sorry about that
wait i did start that i started all day
no this is this is cats got really dark
we just
got dark got really dark got really dark
drink that whiskey chicken
it is about to get a whole lot lighter
yeah it is about to get a whole lot
lighter this is
my uh last episode as a
uh what am i on this the host host
the talent the i'm not no we're all the
talent
last episode as a permanent host
as a permanent host not necessarily
forever just as a permanent host yeah
just as a permanent host i will come in
from time to time yeah baby you know
yeah that makes me happy that's because
chin bullied me i didn't believe he said
i will get that [ __ ] asian gang
i did say that they will [ __ ] see you
riding in your [ __ ] jeep tinted
windows i don't want to do it bro i
don't want to do it those people can't
even tell i'm in my jeep
i like that all right yeah it is pretty
dark yeah yeah i couldn't see it yeah i
was like looking like
yeah there's someone in here
people do that to me all the time even
when i was valet
they were like damn
well i mean because your windows are
super tinted so no yeah uh you know
basically
yeah i just hate talking a lot and i'm
just kidding uh
yeah i'm not doing this podcast or my
podcast and just kind of
you know just not doing podcasting
at all as a guest i'll do podcasting but
i just
i just don't see a
long
long-term
i just don't see longevity in me as a
podcaster
and that's you know yeah we get it you
hate the industry that has given that
career
all of you know
it's done great for people some people
you know dig it but i you know i always
think back to when i first moved here to
uh los angeles
and i moved out here and i was just
doing stand-up and the way that was
going was just so much fun and it still
is and i'm doing a lot more with it and
i've grown a lot with stand up
and i just you know
would prefer to just fully lean into
that because it's just fun and it's it's
hard you know
doing something when you just don't feel
it
and as you guys know me if i'm a person
that doesn't feel something i just won't
[ __ ] do it go off
after yeah i have to be honest with
myself and
i always want to deliver my best for
people and the people that i'm working
with and if i just don't feel and i'm
just fighting it then i just can't
partake in it oh yeah well no we're
we're bombed so you guys don't like me
anymore is that what it is uh we i mean
we like you so much we almost were like
not gonna do the show chin was like i
will not have it
and uh
he had he had the idea that i don't know
why he didn't come to me but we have a
new permanent host and that's a little
bit more oh yeah okay we call them
i that's the plan okay yeah whether you
like me
you bout to get that magic my money oh
wow [ __ ]
that's a that's a funny [ __ ] picture
just growing through memory lane
yeah a montage that was uh that was
that was junior high that was the first
episode of cats
someone said did you go to junior high
in the 60s
what year was that you think the uh
[ __ ] i had to be 14 right there
and so
i'm 35 which that had to be 2001.
yeah
i know
1961.
what's so crazy about that is i wasn't a
[ __ ]
funny guy i was just an angry dude yeah
and they called you class comedian and
they called me a class comedian
and i don't know if it was just because
i would just talk [ __ ] to teachers you
must have been funny you had a minute i
think you had a group of trolls in their
classes that's what i'm saying i think i
think that was a troll i think that was
a troll movie
yeah they did it they did it on me girls
he'll flip out
he'll attack our teacher people knew you
you call me white not flip out
white boy call me that and i [ __ ]
i mean i used to right i get it now yeah
you would have fought theo 80 times
no i'm excited you know for the things
i'm doing and i do have a bunch of road
dates which is cool as well so just come
see me
you know on tour you're in rhode island
this or next weekend uh rhode island's
june
25th
20th
uh 24th june 18th juneteenth yeah that's
what i'm saying
is when i'm in rhode island
none of y'all know what juneteenth is
all right [ __ ] y'all you get shot
that's father's day right
that doesn't have meaning to me either
yeah so yeah i got tour dates you know
just come see mother see me on the road
chapelle lacey.com right that's
palaces.com for all tickets that's where
i'll be talking yeah i'm going to some
cool cities rhode island hey come on
dude are you doing stuff around here
like soon in l.a uh ontario
uh irvine oxner irvine urban
yeah
are
close driving distance ontario is pretty
quick
it's kind of like ontario and oxford i
think like i don't yeah they're like
this they're obviously but they're like
an hour yeah i want to say from out of
los angeles yeah irvine that's in like
september
uh we definitely gotta see him in irvine
oh yeah we'll go yeah everybody improv
yeah sure yeah i'd rather yeah just let
yeah just come hear me talk on stage
just do that
yeah yeah yeah
come back any time you want to plug one
of these dates you open open seat on
that [ __ ] i'm getting a lot of weekends
so
i'll be here
[Laughter]
just plugging dates they call me plug
dog lacy you know what i'm saying oh wow
yeah i don't even know if that sounds
right i don't know if i should close
that sounds kind of bad yeah that sounds
bad
but yeah i'll just keep it a smoke dog
lacy smoking plug
plug dog is like
that's doggy style plug yeah yeah yeah
plug dog i think it just sounds like a
drug dealer it does plug dog
dog
yeah okay yeah are you doing shows in
l.a around here soon uh or is those all
the ones you just yeah you well the la
ones it was so funny someone wrote on my
commented on one of my posts they were
like yo when you coming to los angeles i
was like i live here
[ __ ] here every [ __ ] day
uh
no so like the
hollywood improv and like the comedy
store yeah like laugh
i just put my availability in right like
the
end of every week and they tell me what
i'm doing that following personally but
comics don't like promote those dates
because they're like yeah because this
is just like well no i was just
wondering because my boys are in from
atlanta and i was like dude we could see
some some shows and stuff out here but i
don't know if anyone's doing them while
you guys are here i mean you bring in
any night i think i think i think
brendan's at the lab factory tonight oh
word yeah those are always good shows
too
yeah i think he's i think he's there
tonight
yeah he is
he is okay yeah do that i know jamar
neighbors has a free show in the park
this saturday tomorrow night boy wow boy
and he walked boy yeah yeah he he go
crazy he go hard in the paint i know who
he is what what's it what do you what
can i tell you one of my pets one of his
jokes
i would love to hear it all right this
better not get me canceled
he goes you're not getting us canceled
yeah
and if if so we can edit it out but it's
he's so [ __ ] ruthless and raw and and
he just goes for it he goes
he he looks at the crowd
he goes ladies
would y'all [ __ ] bill cosby and they are
like hill no [ __ ] no [ __ ] [ __ ] no
bill cosby and he goes and that's why he
did it
dude dude
ruthless that's that's actually really
funny but [ __ ] up but
funny
that's a great joke it's a great joke
that's a great job it's a great joke
especially when you get that
he elicits that reaction like [ __ ] no oh
that was that was like that was such a
chess piece move yeah like the way that
joke is so good it's such a good joke he
did it uh i watched him do it every
night he uh he hosted for shane gillis
that bray improv and he just [ __ ]
would do it every time he would do it it
was just and it gets like the biggest
reaction which is cool because it's like
oh these people understand that it's
just a comment it's a joke yeah it's
nothing serious and
those are the crowds like you [ __ ]
wants like legit comedy fans not these
[ __ ] that are analyzing
everything like why what did you mean by
when you said that yeah like eat a dick
sorry if you're talking stand up you
gotta come to one of my shows oh yeah
george
george challenge well
i forget how long you've been doing
stand up uh i started
like two and a half years ago when i
lived in new york um but then i lived in
croatia for a bit so i didn't do
anything there and then it was a
pandemic so like when i came back from
new york i was doing um
like outdoor mics and [ __ ] yeah
yeah and then since i come back came
back i've really been on it yeah yeah
[ __ ] yeah yeah we love you george came
to a show
last friday he big mike he accidentally
got booked on a woke show
yeah it was just it was interesting for
a sorority and they asked anyone they
like as soon as he got done cosby would
have hated that
oh my god
i got it
wait so like a woke show like it was
like i was booked at the ninth for the 9
30
which was like all dudes and then um but
they sent me promo materials and like
links for the 7 30 show which was like a
usc like recent graduate like woke like
kind of discourses a comedy thing so i
get there with like
like i get there i get there with like a
bunch of people
um and then he's like oh you're at the 9
30 show i was like i'm here with people
i'm not gonna make them like wait like
can you get me on 7 30 is like yeah like
go for it
it's the show
like you could definitely tell like the
difference between like like i was out
of place for sure but i still like i
still like i was like all right like i'm
just gonna do this and i still did
really well yeah what's so crazy is you
like you're a genuine dude you seem like
a real sensible man
but meanwhile you feel out of touch with
like woke [ __ ] not saying like
you're like it's weird to just like
you're just a you're a regular dude and
i mean that with all respect yeah yeah
but like just to being a regular person
you're like oh i'm out of place with
these woke [ __ ] yeah they
didn't so did they try to rest because
sometimes they try to um restrict what
you can say yeah restrict what you can
say no no they didn't care um
it went well but it was weird comedy
must be stressful for them as soon as
george
go ahead as soon as george got done the
host was like anyone in the crowd that
came for george if you want to leave you
can
yeah but i don't think they they meant
it and like because that that i wasn't a
part of that show so they're like you
guys don't have to stay for the whole
thing like kind of deal but it was weird
the way it came off because i did crush
it so it was like all right
it just shows that the the the people
organized like
they're like everybody here is under our
sensibility but not like those people
were like oh a joke's a joke that's
funny yeah uh
but the open mic scene is tough like
that you don't know what kind of room
you're walking into my buddy dylan
uh we did it for like we were going
together
like uh not dating we would go
we would go
together and uh at one open mic he has
this joke he was like he went to a rock
climbing wall
and he couldn't find parking but there
were four open handicapped spots
and like i i can't remember his
punchline but the joke like the joke's
right there why are there handicapped
spots and they like
the second he
get sits down they're like oh let's give
it up for dylan who hates the handicap
but like they're not joking they're like
oh wow yeah like oh wow it is it is
weird because like okay let's take all
of us from this room i mean there's a
lot of dicks in here but uh it's only
dicks
yeah all dicks but
think about like i guess when you're
younger did you ever look at comedy and
go and see that someone said something
go oh god i can't believe they said that
no that's [ __ ] ridiculous i wonder
i would love to like understand why it
hurts the person so much when someone
says something
when when the foundation of it all the
intention is just strictly to be [ __ ]
comedy yeah cause i because i i don't
know i don't know if people of that
caliber put comedians in this realm of
like hey when you say things like that
you're you're promoting this because
because
honestly i think that's you're going
after the wrong people when you think
someone's promoting
i don't know negative [ __ ] negative
[ __ ] like that most of the time the
joke someone there's some i think ricky
gervais said it or there's some london
comic who was like
when you're saying something that will
elicit that reaction you're highly it's
satire you're highlighting how absurd
anybody to have that thought is and the
laugh is everybody knowing that's not
okay that's not okay but the people who
don't get it are like you can't say that
it's like you're highlighting that's a
problem so it's like
a good thing that you're you're putting
under a microscope but people think just
because you're repeating it you're
endorsing it is interesting yeah they
take it as like gospel like that's how
like
it is and they take it as like that's
what you truly feel yeah it's like
the dumbest [ __ ] i've ever said in my
life i don't feel this way yeah it's
just dumb it's just funny like it's just
funny
uh we gotta we gotta take some magic
mind before we turn into the
sketch about a white guy podcasting to
another white guy
have people seen that he's like you
can't say anything on stage today bro
it's crazy it's amazing sorry yeah
no no no i was just curious like an
outsider's perspective you know just i
agree and i was getting fired up but
it's
not good
we only have one magic mine today so we
have to spin the wheel thanks brian
cameron all right
yeah
dragon ball next week he loves them i
mean good for me but he took all the
ones that he loves him every morning he
comes in and he shakes him up he's like
i love these magic mic
should we do this shadow james yeah you
can spin it yeah shout out his podcast
you want to do it
check out most recent guest repel lacey
yes
chappelle made me cry like this
like do it hard because
[Music]
what's that say uh c that's chin that's
chin
what does christian get
uh fired if he doesn't
[Laughter]
good toss nick
no problem i mean by the way i love this
stuff i wish i could have it every
single day you can can i you can totally
subscribe ashwagandha echinicia which is
all grab it every day
if you use the promo code cat say d no
no dark cat's dark maya dark dark dark
star
that's okay george it's okay we put a
reel up that's how we learn
oh
yeah
i like that we have an audience today
and don't talk off mike just not if you
uh understand do you guys know what
magic mind is delicious
no magic mind is a once daily shot
all with all natural ingredients 30
grams of caffeine to give you a slow zen
focus throughout the day it's the
anti-procrastination drink if you make
this part of your morning routine you're
going to accomplish all your goals
fellas magic minecraft
slash dark promo code dark 25 off how
was it
i always do every time i taste it it's
more delicious because you get used to
the flavor and you want it you crave it
after a while if you've never had matcha
before it'll have like a bitter taste
but if you had matcha
so they're matcha guys they're all right
they're perfect
magic mine is for you we will introduce
these two fellas yes uh maybe introduce
them right now and we yeah yeah yeah is
my boy austin awake
this is brendan
brennan b-r-e-n-n-e-n right now yeah
because we've been saying that yeah get
mixed up quite a bit
uh yeah they're in from atlanta we're
working on some music together peace out
yeah
sorry i had to do it
these things were savage though i think
the magic mine would work well with them
we first time me and austin linked up
where he was on the liver king [ __ ] so
we were just like eating raw liver and
just wait you guys really were savage
yeah
okay what what is it what's the catch
dude because i guess
he's a fake daddy yeah ruins people's
lives
you guys actually raw liver you're
kidding me dude no i felt no i felt
[ __ ] great after you got me off
i don't believe this literally feels
like steroids
viagra and cocaine i've never done those
but yeah no for real what specific
animal's liver
i think it's a cow i hope right here
yeah see i don't even check that [ __ ]
how'd you guys even get it question hey
that's ordered my first question most
most animals have liver at a restaurant
or you guys no there's a farm like two
hours away from where we live oh if it's
a farm though okay yeah yeah dude i
would love to try that you would you
would try it chin what do you think bro
so he he only eats raw
he don't cook anything no no i guess
he's uh cooked beef but then just like
the organ meat eats raw that's what i
heard oh okay he's supposed to be on
fighting the kid by the way
so what about like chicken because
chicken's got like salmonella no you
can't do that you can't do chicken
were you trying to get me to eat chicken
feet that one horse no no but like raw
right
yeah
raw checking you is sick
or die debatable and this guy's all
natty true i've seen some stuff in japan
where they do uh chicken yeah you have
to like source it like
you have to know exactly where it's
coming from how it's raised and
everything i mean we couldn't do it here
[ __ ] i would love to do it we could we
couldn't do
like in the states yes at the states i
don't know
there might be a restaurant
i've been in the uk too i know you've
changed can we all do it here yeah
i chase i said the story's improper
brows has a pretty good impression of
liver king
testicle one i feel like honestly
brennan is better yeah brandon doesn't
have a good one hit us with it well let
me wait i don't know his voice every
we're in an airbnb together and this is
all i hear in the morning this is what
wakes me up don't do it don't do it yeah
let me hear his voice i don't know what
he sounds like me either
no you gotta find one of his ones like
where he wakes up like go to his story
go to his instagram story like
and just listen how he talks in the
morning
damn it's even more jack now
but he says there's one thing in the
morning every morning his first story
and it's all i hear from this guy in the
morning
hey primals
that's going out to the beach we're
getting grounded in the earth
[Laughter]
three ounces of liver with breakfast
lunch and dinner you guys serve uh raw
liver here this is starbucks
he asked for liver out of starbucks
today
yeah i could i uh i don't know
he's testing ask him if he's natty when
he's not
i know that's a big topic and it's
very difficult for him to answer
correctly which we all i'm everyone here
what do you guys think
i i i would say no yeah i would say no
too probably also just because someone
does steroids i mean who cares they're
going to look like that yeah you know he
that's like mark your boy mark who knows
everything about bodybuilding and
steroids and everything else he was
saying like mark doesn't do steroids no
he does he does
but he said this guy has a natural
physique
this guy's a natural build and physique
like he he was meant to be like exactly
that's what i'm saying like some people
don't even realize like yeah
like i think if i took steroids i don't
know there's no way out yeah even dude
there's no way
well maybe you because maybe you maybe
no because we saw your body before when
you're cheerleading are you all looking
at
body obvious you're freaking ripped no
it
my
we should do we should like i mean all
you guys should like just go on a raw
liver diet and see if you can get like a
vegan we could try it on the show so
chapel can't do it right now how
i i
love
i love a contest like this like any
reason to i don't know like one time on
the adam curl a show for two weeks i i
lost 18 pounds in like
10 days
and i thought i was going to die
from doing what not eating
oh no i ate like one thing of veg
vegetables a day it was a contest to see
who could lose the most weight in two
weeks and then the last day i was trying
to lose water wig i was like jumping
outside in the summer with like a
garbage bag and [ __ ] but uh i ran out of
time and i was like christian they're
like where the [ __ ] is nick we need him
to switch cameras
shout out george
i heard if you ate salad every day you
just get bloated
like it does i heard it's not like good
for you to just eat salads just only
salad is that yeah your heaviest yeah
well hey how about you there 51 451.
shout out to four four whoa joe you
better get 451 tattooed on you hell yeah
maybe when i that is good it's hard
maybe when i get it
removed that could be my rib tattoo yeah
how you got it across your ribs yeah
again 405 or 451 451. i don't know what
error
i'm gonna say that's like maryland
i was gonna say like george or something
uh i have no i'm just guessing i like
guessing area because me too it's fun
because it does kind of go across the
united states yeah it's interesting did
you used to ship for a job
i used to pack all these packages
oh so you knew it was it was the zip
code that actually was more accurate to
like yeah going across the house uh what
is it
i love the idea of the all liver diet
where do how do i get enough liver
to sustain my to do this i think i don't
know if we can plug them but it's the
farm like two hours away they ship it it
comes in like dry ice frozen and it's
like the liver doesn't taste as bad as
you would think it's the it's like the
texture of it it's terrible so they they
ship across the country i think so oh
yeah all right i'm going to reach out
this week and see if that they'll shut
up
i thought it was going to be crazy bad
though because like his girl was like
popping in her mouth and chasing it with
orange juice and stuff i was like that
is
this white oak pastures uh yep yeah this
is it that looks awesome
the street i grew up on was white oak so
oh
yeah it went down there
in uh
atlanta you're from new york i'm from
new york upstate there's a white oak
because there's a white house just done
i like how they put the road to put the
rosemary right there oh yeah
it doesn't come with it doesn't it
and the liver does not look that good
uh we do you guys want to slide down
bring bring you want to sit up it's over
here brother
yeah
just ordered 10 pounds of liver after he
tried it we tried it on the boat and he
was like i feel pretty good he went in
order too
this girl was like this is the closest
i've had to a psychedelic experience
like experience it's weird you feel it
it's weird it's like licking a frog but
i'm the i'm placebo poppy so i don't
know
everything makes me feel [ __ ] weird
yeah everything i was in i was hoping
well no i know say the magic mind i was
hoping i didn't get chosen oh yeah i was
like doing it it started to feel weird
i was freaking out
you're like is this anxiety
like this i just had like i didn't know
i just had basically seven shots of
espresso and i thought it wasn't like
that bad and then brennan was like
you're gonna die and then i was like
dude i might die yeah yeah i'm jealous
of the being placebo yeah because like
i'll take champion this ain't working
and then it hits at once then it all
hits out yeah then i'm like i'm gonna
die
hours later that's why i won't do an
editable thing
don't ever do edibles huh don't ever do
edibles man especially if you if you
have that mindset like that's me i want
to be i want to be in control
did you do the first the joke oh my god
those are one of the worst experiences
how much did you take
we [ __ ] up because we
uh one of our friends he didn't know how
to make edibles so he put like weed like
i guess he cooked it into into butter
and then you spread the butter onto
bananas
and the banana bread is amazing right so
i i ate a bunch and i'm like i don't
feel [ __ ] like after like five minutes
eight more anymore
we were [ __ ] i didn't know where i
was at we went
i remember like holding on to my friend
inside a nightclub and i'm like we need
to call the ambus call the ambulance i'm
dying i'm dying you're not dying i'm
dying i'm dying were you following him
around like like this yeah
oh my god dude and we found a little
corner to sit down i was like oh and
it's i just saw like did you puke yeah
no you didn't puke i just saw colors and
flowers
it was it sucked it made me cry
it made you cry yeah so you've done
edibles then yeah yeah i just don't like
to but i did it when it was i think we
talked about this last time i did it
when it wasn't as controlled as it is
like there was no five milligrams yeah
exactly you had a buddy making banana
bread no you know in a different way you
got his uh it was a buddy that lives in
denver and he brought some to vegas when
we were in vegas for a bachelor party i
[ __ ] that dude yeah never again
yeah the easiest way to do edibles
because like some people are like oh you
gotta make the butter or whatever if you
just get peanut butter
uh and it's better if it has like a like
the natural oil in or something but
there's these things called firecrackers
we made for a road trip to go to panama
city beach in college because the guy
who was driving didn't want us to smoke
in the car it's like 24 hours gotta get
high
we gotta figure this out
but uh so four hours did you
drive there yeah yeah i i drove from on
the way back we someone did a shift but
then i drove 17 straight hours
of them firecrackers i know right uh we
listened to nick schwartzen seriously
who farted uh oh that's that's a great
memory
we were all
that's my favorite part my favorite part
was like he's talking about uh
he used to like to go to bars and we'd
get real wasted he'd go up to people and
he'd pull out his dick and he'd pull it
over his recipe oh yeah do you know what
time it is
and he pulls it up to a girl and she's
like that's your dick
that's so funny his girl impression is
really good yeah yeah he's a question of
girls he goes let me let me show or show
my boyfriend he's like okay
and he shows a boyfriend then guy goes
is that your [ __ ]
he's just gonna go zero to a hundred so
fast that's so funny that was filmed in
austin texas
firecracker
okay so what does it consist of ritz
ritz cracker peanut butter just sprinkle
peanut butter on top of it then try to
like sandwich you can't sprinkle pickles
sorry sprinkle the weeds
there you go you're right it gets messy
[Laughter]
and then another ritz cracker then you
wrap it up in foil put it in the
microwave for a couple minutes and then
you put it in the oven
that's it right there oh yeah you can't
put foil in the microwave either way
yeah you just put the ritz cracker in
the microwave and then you when you come
out you wrap them in foil
there you go there we go then the thc
can't escape but they work and they're
extremely powerful but you don't know i
could tell they were powerful he took
edibles before the show that's why he
said this yeah
before the show no no no i'm just
kidding oh uh meatball do you have a
weed pen
damn meatball got that backwards it's
called job security yeah
too if you want we can light up no we
absolutely cannot
[Laughter]
also who smokes
what is it edibles
mike tyson
oh oh his ear bites i heard those are so
crazy though that's what they're called
take one too no [ __ ] no they're shaped
like ears have you tried
yeah i mean this won't hit me until
after oh yeah ted
oh my god nick i'm not gonna lie they
are pretty strong that's what i heard
dude
no no
[Laughter]
he's
good they have a better flavor called
watermelon unreal
i've never heard of this watermelon cold
watermelon yeah on a mic in a microscope
i took like three of them last night and
talked to chappelle for like three hours
do not remember the conversation
[Laughter]
that would be
the time was moving very slow that's
where it was it felt like three hours i
actually would like you to pull the call
out
he screenshots it after the call they're
like
whoa
whoa
is it like when you walk around on the
phone you're like outside you're walking
around bro michael this guy will be
riding this skateboard and [ __ ] my call
log uh let's see chappelle lacey
chapelle lacey chappelle
heck is going on
there's all one call yeah
you mean cumulative
this morning
30 30 minutes this morning
i had two missed calls from you at 7 47
and 7 48 this morning i'm usually up by
six um checks out last night
39 minutes okay uh
yesterday i'm waiting for the three hour
i'm waiting for the three hour 39
minutes on the phone would feel like
three hours
especially off that yeah
yeah for firecrackers yeah yeah you feel
it
[Laughter]
let's see what else we got here oh god
there's no three hour then cause you're
a liar
three hours i have a lot of missed calls
from you jesus bro
no it's because you've been deleting
[ __ ] and you just put my name up there i
know yeah he deletes everyone else's
calls that have been called up yeah
yeah i
do cool
yeah i do 40 minutes that's a solid
conversation i think you're a good
friend yeah yeah no i'm not okay it is
cool it is i just don't make me look
like a [ __ ] loser
no i just i was so high just made me
look like a [ __ ] nerd because like
what call i want to talk to a friend nah
i like it it makes my day next time you
guys have a heart to heart can you
explain to him call times
chipotle calls me i'm like dude we've
been talking for like [ __ ] three
hours it's been like five minutes now
yeah exactly uh that's not the call time
i'm talking about this is why you have
to talk to the man
it's a hard thing
i know i'm sorry i had work i had other
work to do i'm sorry
the call time it's like the
industry talk we spoke about having two
jobs at once it is difficult but you got
to make it work oh you guys you guys
call each other on the phone too oh god
no no
it's just like decline
what's so funny is i talk so much [ __ ]
to kristen when i talk to him all the
time
sometimes i'll call him like yo you
[ __ ] dumb
i'll start the conversation like that he
could be dude he was uh where did you
get
frozen yogurt last night yeah dude
you're gonna grow your losers
i put one of the edibles in the frozen
yogurt unreal um and like i was like
having a great night i was coming home
i'm gonna watch a movie great mood
awesome i just got a call from chappelle
you're [ __ ] ugly
there
i was all happy and then like everything
getting ready to play call of duty and
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] loser christian you
should move the mic george so you can be
on camera no like just next to me right
there there you go yeah but i ask again
do you have a vape pen
oh yeah
but i ask again
but
i think we talked for three hours
uh should we do news for george what
should we talk about now i don't know
actually i want tell us more about
who we're sitting with yeah your boys
which is what are we working on
we just met we bonded yesterday we had a
we had a nice talk we did a hike
um would you all hate do you like
running we did to mescal canyon
and he showed up straight savage mode i
think he had like some sort of
uh
satchel it had like a
like a shaw that just tied around the
other side that didn't work everything
kept falling out of it and delaying the
like he's trying to put like coconut
water in there
oh yeah hey
looking at you
hey look at that you dog you [ __ ] with
coconut water
he rolled up here in this gear i was
like yeah that's coconut water but like
everyone we were passing he kept being
like almost out of coconut water
or miles from civilization
doesn't coconut water just hit you
quicker i guess with hydration yeah it's
got like there's something i see a
minute so it kind of locks in
that hydration you don't get cramped up
yeah for like
see all these people are taking all
these [ __ ] crazy ass
powdered [ __ ]
i know what you just do that before
yeah for the pre-workouts and [ __ ]
that's cocaine that would drive less
crazy oh yeah
yeah
do like placebo puppies where you try
different things and just see if it's
not
i don't know any amount of money that i
do that's hard for you no no stress
he's like but also check the card
[Laughter]
definitely go but if it's not no big
deal
who the [ __ ] is this kid
that's coconut head from that's
declassified
he was talking about coconuts and it
reminded me of coconut head
do you know that yeah that's our
generation
he looks
this is a real kid
no it's a character
leave that window up so is that you side
by side is that his normal face
i don't mean that in disrespect it's
just i've never seen a human look like
that
no is that weird no no who was that kid
he's a character from the tv show now
that's really classified
it's like how chin doesn't know nick at
night like
you know that declassified was right
under there you see what it looks like
now yes sir
okay cool that's oh this is him now now
uh he should have kept the coconut head
there and
here's nemo that's emo phillip
yeah similar
damn evil phil is he old now i'm glad
some person in the room who you know
yeah when i worked at the comedy tour
day he was like he'd always have he'd
sell out the week in minneapolis oh yeah
of course he would he's like a one
one-liner comedian
but he's just he's just he's been around
for like uh
he's santa barbara yeah barbara this
weekend right
see right yeah right that's another one
you guys don't know these guys i know i
think this is awesome you guys pound
hard dude like i won't worry about whoa
because he's not edible i mean i'm just
saying
[ __ ]
hard
i heard you guys
you guys pound heart
it does numbies
[Applause]
[Laughter]
own he is
and then christian of course is on the
phone yeah get that [ __ ] dog
yeah damn
edible
i know dude nick's going to be gone
incredible i feel like we're schultzy
joe rogan
times a week three hours from seven to
ten on tuesdays and thursdays is podcast
and smoke weed it's just a constant
thing so yeah i think you can handle it
usually it's about five claws
but
is that one of those crystal meth pens
to us
that's our culture
we're placebo culture over here
yeah i don't know what's in that pen
cause i've never seen him look like that
so i don't trust that one yeah what
that's the kind of that or that's the
brand
that's a kind of meth it's kind of bad
to us that's the kind of myth what's
funny is i bought two two brand new pods
and i went back to rhode island for my
grandfather's funeral and uh i went to
take it out of my pocket and i dropped a
brand new pod in the funeral home so
someone found a brand new pod and i
couldn't really ask anyone for it
because it was so you got a new one yeah
it kind of sucked brand new one lost
he
saw what he did
he saw two people doing crack oh yeah
and i didn't even know crack was still
around that's dope yeah dude i saw some
dude smoking crack
outside panda express then ran and
started calling everyone just started
walking in a circle like going pedophile
oh my god
that spin
yeah why'd you do the spin with him
because that's what he did oh
so if you're in this line of sight you
get hit with it i guess so like yeah
it's like a bottle yeah
you guys know that yeah uh
it seems like people are getting over it
quick with proceed yeah it's the first
disease but anyways
uh but uh so then my girlfriend she she
took a at home test she tested positives
then she like
i don't know
she likes getting tested so she wanted
to go to walgreens and uh she scheduled
like one of the ones through the
drive-through or whatever and at the
drive-through
can you
accept this airdrop christian on your
computer
excuse me uh
when you go through the drive-through
it's like basically the size of your car
but there's like a old old asian man on
one side and a young black lady on the
other side both look like they've been
on the streets foreign and like you
cannot drive through without almost
running over their feet i should have
said and uh but my girlfriend's so nice
she's like just talk to them like people
they'll move she's like i'm trying to
get a test and they they did they they
like moved out of the way but
just sitting there right outside the the
walgreens window they're doing crack
and then like a security guard walks up
yeah he was like is that doing crap
did those come through no uh
so this was like a drive-through like
mcdonald's drive-through no
like a pharmacy drive through okay yeah
i didn't know if it was because you guys
have records
i don't even know no
i thought that was like the
pharmacy
[Music]
i just imagine like someone giving out a
happy meal and then a covet test
vaccine that wasn't the ticket yeah
shout out go and go poppy covid with
diabetes i don't know how they i don't
know why they did that it worked for me
uh but uh yeah it was a it was an
alarming scene they were doing crack
right there some giant jacked security
guard walks over he's like man what the
[ __ ] wrong with you i don't care what
you do but do it around the corner and
he like walked him and they're doing cbs
you know that's the competition
and then they kind of talk [ __ ] back to
him he's like i disrespect you a day in
my life
i'm telling you you can't be doing this
here and he walked him away and his
black person impression is really good
so he was black and a security guard
yeah
i didn't do a black person impression i
didn't i did an impression of that man
whose race i had yet to specify
the fact that you got that means i did a
good impression
think you said it was a big black jack
security guard no i did not say that's
your brain i said brows yeah that's what
he said when i said the crack addicts i
said an asian man and a black young
black lady but i did not say race for
the security guard oh you did it yeah
did you say jack though yes okay he
didn't say jet he said big jack security
guard yeah and you were just looking at
shipping
very carefully he did look at me when he
was explaining it
sometimes when i go a little ratio i do
look at my kids they're so cute
[Laughter]
which is the most racist thing about
about the way you tell it
the naughty approval
oh whoa whoa whoa
nick's edible kick loose we're getting
loose did your edible kick in i think
baby
i think maybe
so you don't smoke weed or do anything
no cause you don't vape just like with
the caffeine one time i got super high
and this yeah this man told me i was
gonna die and that was like the last
time i smoked yep so you're getting that
no my boy brandon same thing wait
where's your when was your birthday
there's a connection here july no no i'm
january
that setup didn't work
but to js they're both js they're both
just j's okay
true finding the connection i also
tested negative uh
by the way otherwise i don't believe you
right sorry i thought of that when i
coughed really loudly
like it's weird cause like you don't
even look like you had covet
i i don't i look like i had it looking
so much weight looking back on last
tuesday's episode recorded i hadn't
tested positive yet i definitely had
covenant
i looked like i was going to die in our
episode
[Laughter]
no i didn't even put myself in the
thumbnail because i was like i look
sweaty
sickly
so you actually felt some [ __ ] is this a
video i thought it was because i told
you guys i destroyed my body with
alcohol at palm springs oh yeah you did
say that and anytime i don't sleep i've
that's the only time i've gotten sick in
my life it's like oh i have like i got
like four hours of sleep over two nights
you run down yeah but so i thought i was
just feeling like i was recovering from
that but like
weakened my body got covered excreted
out of my body like wolverine and now
we're fine so you probably tested like
as you were on like that
on thursday it was like a horrible day
like flu chills
diarrhea oh this is your first time
getting it
uh i think i might add it around
christmas it was my first time i ever
tested
literally the first time i ever took a
test but i think i had around christmas
but like we were i was just at home and
like
everybody my whole family had it so this
is the cv or the walgreens video yeah uh
i don't even know if it's worth it
anymore but um
because we were talking about jokovic if
you go to did you jump
you think those crackheads got covered
there's one of the security guards
they're invincible they're resilient
i don't think they can't
just kills it crack kills
yeah
that you were a crack at it because
there's probably some entrepreneurial
people be like this these free crack
pipes aren't going to last forever i'm
going to get a bunch now and sell them
later i wonder if they were going to do
like an extorted
extraordinary task like do a backflip
off a bridge or something
what was i saying i had a question
was it about crack i had a question dude
it was about crack yes yes yes thank you
i wonder if they were trying to
say yes i have it we could all do it
right now no i said i haven't oh you
haven't
uh no i was when they were giving out
the free crack pipes i wonder if they
were trying to pull some amsterdam [ __ ]
because like isn't
drugs legal in like amsterdam like
anything out there but and they have you
like do it
legalize everything
so they did it are you screen recording
yeah
legalize mushrooms and stuff
maybe not portland maybe seattle someone
just legalized black tar heroine i
actually did see that
y'all see that underbelly the dude
that's like a functioning heroin addict
no but that's where amsterdam does that
right they do like
hospitals whatever you can go there or
clinics you can go there just to get
heroin a little dosa it was on rogan
which sounds freaking amazing oh i think
they have better like crime rates and
stuff because they legalize it and yeah
they have monthly they just like do it
medically so they like dose people up
kind of like a methadone clinic almost
like just enough to get them through the
day yeah i keep doing more like and hair
will last all day
i don't know i probably like i don't
know have you ever done it i've never
done it
i wonder you have to prove you're an
addict because what if i just want to do
a little bit of heroin in a controlled
environment for the first time check it
out
dr carl heart race doesn't that sound
awesome though
what y'all [ __ ] are crazy i
don't want to do it but i feel like if
they just give me a little i won't get
addicted yeah but well you're gonna
you'll get obviously feels amazing
that's a yeah that's it for sure yeah
without a doubt it has to be amazing
it might get sick but if you give it a
little bit though just a little bit yeah
just a tiny dose
so this so that's the only way you can
get heroin in amsterdam is if you go to
a doctor and i'm like hey man i need my
fix
have you ever been in amsterdam
no yeah you can get it illegally but the
fact that they're doing it you know in a
clinic in that kind of environment it's
kind of like it's pretty cool yeah
well it's cool to us because it's
illegal here but to them they're
probably like oh yeah you just go there
but then you're saying like it's safer
there there's
less crimes probably dropped the amount
of
people wanting to do heroin yeah and
overdosing and going crazy just just
like just getting their fix you could
die from withdrawal too right if you go
crazy
why is that what is what is it i think
only like alcohol and like xanax or like
very specific stuff you have to wait
from smart guy almost died on espn's
playmakers when he was withdrawing from
heroin minutes before a nfl game was
really interesting heroin wait oh i love
smart guy let's show you yeah which one
was mo
the actor who played marcus
marcus was the brother his best friend
was moe oh yeah
mo moe in real life played a football
player in this show espn playmakers it
was incredible at one season the nfl
wouldn't license it they're like can we
see who moe is i can't remember he was
gonna you'll be like oh mo
uh and but then in in the show mo one of
the story lines was he was addicted to
heroin he was a star running back and he
almost died of withdrawals minutes
before the game and he isn't pads no
that's cute and this man
in pads meet someone like in like the
the there might be a mix up the drive up
just like cuban junior that's his
brother yeah it is
he that is cuba getting junior's brother
yes this is his younger brother omar
gooding omar gooding yeah oh yeah he
totally looks like
cuba the i the fact that i didn't know
that i loved cuba
wait he really had a heroin overdose no
no
playmakers
you're right
[Laughter]
that's why i was so confused i was like
if it's the mo i'm thinking of type in
omar gooding playmakers
nice
i remember i remember him now the show
was incredible i was we were oh [ __ ]
i think this does look like a show you
would watch it was like the real side of
the nfl
that's how they like tried to promote it
but
he bought heroin
in pads in where like they the delivery
bay of some football stadium it was
insane the show was amazing
what year was this this had to be like
2005. yeah yeah right around around
there yeah it looks very 2005
yeah right
this show is amazing it's about to be
kickoff time
are you sure you want to do this right
now 2003 even the dealer is saying that
to him thank you mike tyson this is i'm
just having a flood of memories this
show is incredible yeah
oh you saw it
so i don't know i haven't thought of
playmakers for a decade but
[Laughter]
just shows you don't think about should
we get some news with george let's get
some news with jordan oh and
we gonna meet you too yeah so just just
you you should yeah you oh i literally
wait i really thought you guys were
talking to somebody behind me i was so
confused let's see about poppy
you guys just met yesterday on a hike oh
yeah that's right
yeah yeah we got distracted by the
coconut water i'm sorry i'll be quiet
yeah the crack in the coconut water yeah
me and brennan have been best friends
since basically eighth grade science
class
when the teacher was talking about magic
johnson and he goes yeah he had a lot of
magic in his johnson
and i was like all right this dude's
gonna be my friend
aids magic
all right and then the teacher calls his
uh
his phone to or calls his mom but it was
really just his phone and left the
voicemail on his phone and he played it
for me after class was like it's my boy
but yeah i do music
um i'm an artist austin awake got you
know
he's super dope yeah fire we were making
some stuff last night me him and chen
were super talented
yeah yeah
but yeah we just linked up when i was in
atlanta and then off linkedin yeah i hit
him up on linkedin
bro it was grindr why are you lying
i i hit you up on all of them
and uh
no like right when we right when we
linked up we started just making music
together and like made like just five
like hits in a row i heard them they're
[ __ ] dope dude yeah this was uh
recent this is like yeah a couple weeks
ago i think and uh we just started
making music together oh so this this is
unheard like you guys haven't played
oh wow they're like they're bangers i'm
pumped on them yeah yeah pretty dope
and i i can i can tell a quiet
confidence like you're not i'm sure
you've had like a bunch of
accomplishments you could like say for
yourself but
you don't want to but like
just on a terse
research
uh and this sucks this is the way the
world works he's got 173 000 instagram
followers
and it's music related he's doing
something something right he's got like
mad subs on youtube too i feel like like
hundred and eleven thousand youtube
subscribers oh [ __ ] almost happened it's
so hard to get youtube subscribers too
man it's so difficult
yep love numbies yeah
but yeah so me and brows i think we're
gonna drop a project and
dumb the vibe is just sick like he
hasn't done much features like other
than the last project i really haven't
done any like i have features with like
some bigger artists that haven't come
out yet but um i just been
we just been vibing so yeah
you're originally from new york but you
live in atlanta yes i lived out in cali
out here and then moved back home to new
york then down to atlanta okay as you're
working with record labels and stuff so
and you guys met in new york new york
women in atlanta
yeah oh god uh so i was in
it
i was actually in san diego for a little
while
yup yeah good thing i was gonna wear
that exact outfit today so good thing i
didn't no one would have noticed it's
all right
you should have rocked that yeah yeah
that would have been fire i think
chappelle was roasting me in atlanta he
said something yeah yeah he said i think
you
said something about jb or
something the white boys in atlanta got
swag he's like people showing up at fake
chains or something oh
that was me
but it was was it real
yeah it's real yeah
just making sure
[Laughter]
is today
yeah
that was back in february though yeah
i don't think it was out oh actually
yeah it was yeah it was as cold as
[ __ ] yeah it was i didn't realize it
got cold there like that yeah but right
now it's like almost a hundred oh really
oh it gets humid there yeah crazy nobody
wants to even go outside but i mean
that's what arizona be like yeah we just
met that's the first banger we made is
this song called arizona yeah and it's
like is it is it for me no that's like
cool he's like [ __ ] yeah
yeah
kind of wild but
it's probably 170 followers you got a
wisconsin in the pipeline
yeah we're working on it i just don't
know anything that rhymes with it yeah
mansion
yeah whiskey did it
uh austin can i ask you something yeah
are you black
no no just like i'm mixing everything
like i have some native americans some
italians some
german i was just mixing everything oh
okay yeah yeah yeah you framed that dude
from the uk i know are you playing
do you guys know maya rudolph is half
black
everybody knew this i didn't know this
why are you serious yeah my girl oh my
god yeah i i didn't know oh i didn't
what did you think she was puerto rican
i thought she was i thought she was a
tan white girl
[Laughter]
that's absolutely the biggest lie i've
ever seen in my life
yeah she's just actually no okay no no
no
parker okay something different isn't
there a uh isn't
that hitting you hard isn't it i mean
the worst thing to do is like bring more
light to it
like [ __ ] [ __ ] producers just and he
brings the mic over
not the end okay all right
do you remember the question no i don't
gotta ask you said my rudolph's brain is
downloading
isn't there a black guy who like claims
to be black but everyone is like he's
not and he's like whiter than me is he
the activist guy
yeah that [ __ ] guy yeah ironically
yeah
no it's not sean white sean
oh
it might be that
oh so yeah they that guy yeah this guy
yeah this guy people don't know if he's
he's white is that eric griffin
[Laughter]
uh
sean white or what sean king on his uh
new show i'm not gonna ruin it but you
guys should definitely watch it they
make fun of him so hard on him yeah
because i don't yeah people don't know
what he is and i i can't really tell
either but it's like that's why i
couldn't tell with you because i'm like
this guy's got to fade i do get people
ask me a lot i don't know you get asked
a lot if i'm like spanish because you
look kind of like like like like blake
griffin yeah i get that you get that too
so that's why i was like you got the
same like yeah jason kidd jason yeah
yeah all that all yeah all the above
yeah you know yeah you know you're lying
yeah
he also blew me away when i found out
he's black he was
wild right he was my early 2000s maya
rudolph yeah
yeah
i love how you're getting like blown
away by all these people
you know he's killing it as a coach
see jason kade got perfect like
progressively
wider it is funny yeah did you ever see
the time where he was like they didn't
have any timeouts
so he purposely ran into someone spilled
water on the court smart uh
so they had to do a delay of game and
they got to huddle up and get a last
shot and then the nba did they win the
game uh i can't remember what happened
but the nba find him because it was like
so clearly intentional jason kidd yeah
coach was like i'll cover that fine
he was the coach
oh he did it
yeah
i think for the bucks
oh that's so smart out of someone's hand
see he's still got he goes hit me he
goes hit me
oh wow
he's fly
he's not dead you can't sneak stuff by
in this social media world you know yeah
everybody's gonna see it and post it
like it was brooklyn
shout out to you know austin for being
black
and he makes hip-hop
yeah yeah people call you blake griffin
a lot
nah i've got i've gotten some weird
things but never played griffin no
people have said blake griffin
yeah people have just said like
different things to make fun of me but i
don't i take blake griffin as a
compliment cause i'm like yeah i can
dunk over a car yeah
if it's a man yeah he's really funny
yeah he's really [ __ ] nasty at
basketball he's getting like sick threes
no problem oh really that was my first
level i was supposed to go to college
for but i left after a week
we haven't played yet we got
what are your parents
uh so my mom is more like italian
or irish and then my dad's side is like
a native american
yeah i see it i could be totally wrong
but i think
he's like i'm rolling
right now yeah i don't even know my mom
didn't really even know her dad so there
could be some you know i'm saying
something could have gotten sprinkled in
there
[Laughter]
how long have you been going i don't
know hour 20 damn that's one of the
longest ones i guess we could want to
get one quick animal in real quick sure
yeah
nick sent me this earlier in the week
saw that this is a freaking coyote that
tried to attack this house and this cat
defended the honor of this place
well i was trying to get the cat
respect no this cat this guy has honor
code cats yup this coyote was trying to
kill this family
this caster small coyote too though
they're all that kind of size look at
her
excuse me yeah
i don't think coyotes are like huge they
don't this is right here right oh he got
him yep
watch watch he
[Applause]
and then
that's the first time i'm seeing a cat
not being able to get sick
and then the cat just stays i feel like
we just watched a flashback fight night
especially the way it looks
that's that's crazy
i can't find the punch line but
something about catatonic
i like that
i follow cabinets like this on
instagram
what this is sad ending sad ending not
super sad but
oh what just cuz it's posted up there
that stripper cat on the pole
oh this one cuts off
it falls it just fell but then it
doesn't it probably landed on his feet
but you can't see it it's like behind
the fence i think the castle had another
feet
but
it was a funny ending
yeah so earlier in the week i sent that
to george so we could watch it on the
show
pretty cool
uh well i just want to say thank you
guys you know you guys are amazing
people
means a lot and uh
you know like i said uh just come see me
on the road and [ __ ] you know that's
where
you'll find me doing [ __ ] oh yeah oh
yeah so you still gonna pop on here from
time to time yeah i'll pop on here from
time to time and stuff but oh yeah yeah
look at you
i love it dude i'm you know i miss you
man it sucks that you're not on the
shows i told you when you left firing
the kid i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm bummed out
and then now this i told you how much it
hurts
genuinely like as a fan perspective you
were very positive 45 minutes hour 15 of
my week you know what i mean so like
you mean a lot to a lot of people yeah
that's cool so hope you feel bad
you gotta take care of you you gotta do
what's best for you though yeah you're
sure yeah average yes and like i mean
i've been getting nothing but love from
people anyway you know yeah i think yeah
you guys all have my
back and you know you guys have
supported me all the way and support me
and continue to support me
and it's good it's a good feeling that
you know to be able to
you know exit out of something like this
and not have any weird bad blood or
anything and just
that that makes me feel good you know
that that i can do that so i appreciate
you guys
you know for showing me love you know
thank you guys yeah i've been here since
day one roger and i so this is this is
the writer
there's only two people in this room me
and brennan like that being the world
you guys actually would like to announce
you're starting a podcast
yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
if i look at a tv too long bro i'm
[ __ ] scared
it actually drops the same exact time as
this show every single week yeah
well i'm excited to hear you guys as
[ __ ] too yeah we'll play something you
guys got music yeah yeah yeah
is there is there that's my problem with
you artists give us a date and a
deadline and
what project are we looking out for oh
wow we need to hear your [ __ ] i can't
nothing we don't have the deadline yet
but we're gonna drop some songs together
and then me and chen are doing a full
album together so that's all on the
horizon but we'll play some stuff on
here too
make up a date and then just be like
this is our finish line
the process is such a tricky process not
as like
like easy as like this like you come in
you do this you know exactly what you're
gonna do yeah as far as like timing and
like understanding because there's so
much to look at with music it's like oh
does this part does this version sound
better than what they recorded right
here or whatever this take that take you
know there's oh i get it that's why i'm
saying make it up just fine i'll make it
up oh yeah we do have tonight yeah we do
have a release day that comes out today
right yeah
8pm 8pm yeah yeah yeah yeah wait so when
does this episode drop oh i like smart
uh tomorrow actually okay then oh that
works perfect because he already
announced on chapelle's world
that i'm not doing it and then so it's
cool that yeah and then just follow up
you did your spell world is out yeah
yeah cool
already announced it plotting on nick's
world over there
[Laughter]
that's a nice [ __ ] set you're just
leaving there and it is pretty specific
to you
it's like i can do something with this
can i at least one of those chairs i'd
love it
[Laughter]
it'd be too low for a desk over there
[Applause]
uh all right you guys got music coming
out george what are you plugging uh you
can check me out on my youtube channel
go george go or on instagram
georgeharris48
here's me it's all pretty
nice that's a cool that's a cool that
your profile pic is pretty cool thank
you reuben made it for me shout out
such a beast i'm on myspace
there you go [ __ ] yeah shout out to you
i got a couple spots in my top eight for
you know if anybody is trying to get in
there it looks like you only got one
left
[Laughter]
but what is your instagram and youtube
and all that stuff uh everything is just
austin awake
awesome awake yeah okay austin awake
yes brennan
he's not on so he's not a social media
guy
that's doping on our socials that's you
look like a guy who would not be on
social media i'm not gonna lie yeah i
think i got banned so
oh i got banned from tick tock so if it
makes you feel better
because you like you crushed it in the
twitch game like early on didn't you
yeah yeah you used to like stream back
in the day but uh when we got into this
music marketing business out in atlanta
i kind of just
went went all in on that yeah oh yeah
what did meatball just do everything's
behind the scenes
also i'm not sure if i'm just losing my
mind but please tell me that he am i the
only one that thinks he looks like this
guy
um well you're probably way off meatball
as usual but go ahead yeah dude that's
50 cent looks like this guy i know right
someone just completely no
so funny
like a little bit no maybe if you had
some issues
that's like this a little bit bro bro
how are you how are you going bro how
funny is that bro he's been making
scooby doo jokes for a whole week i see
what you're saying christian i see what
you're saying but it's mostly the hair
yeah
christian like three when that movie
came out
of my favorite movies oh it's fine i
literally asked the trader joe yeah i
was like you see that new scooby-doo
just like yesterday
yeah but then he [ __ ] rocked your
world he's like yeah
why did you ask him about a new
scooby-doo movie is there one out and
he's like i don't know
that's hard
well matt that's matthew lillard and he
uh and the rest of the screencast are
holding out and they're not going to do
another one they're standing strong so
my buddy
has to do with money huh my buddy plays
soccer against matthew oh really
that's how you do it inside info yeah
for a paramount
soccer team
one of the characters
who is he playing screaming
uh
the
the friend who i don't know he gets
killed he's one of the keys no he's one
of the killers right yeah in the first
one yeah but then somehow how is he
still a character
i don't know i didn't watch multiple
ones
oh [ __ ] he'd be like freaking out for a
minute oh yeah yeah he's wondering he
does that funny dance scene and uh
what's that the longer this gets the
longer it takes me to edit guys
uh
you can just follow me on instagram at
cpalo 6 or tick tock christian.palo
account yeah i had 30 000 then i showed
my balls got banned now i'm at 11 000
because i haven't showed my ball so
we're good that's still respectable 11
000 yeah that's good yeah do you have in
your account
uh
30k lost oh yeah yeah dude you should
that's pretty good i'm not getting
hacked at one million i'm not giving
them any immunizations if i say balls i
might get deleted again i don't know i
have six community gyno in violations
already so
i'm here
[ __ ] you get banned like now
where it's like a joke like not even bad
and i and they get taken down yeah it's
super vague too like
they just sort of like get this one
against community guidelines and we
can't tell you why yeah
half the [ __ ] things from king to
sing whenever i would post a clip 90 of
them would get either shadow band sound
removed or taken down so yeah
yeah which was always like really hard
to check when i was like why wasn't this
posted
[Laughter]
i can't i believe yeah i know i'm not
okay anymore so i can't just take your
abuse
oh we did mike we got some music
oh [ __ ] yeah what do you got going on uh
so yeah we're me and well also our
concerts right we have one or two coming
up yeah the first one that's going to be
in austin yeah austin texas august 12th
do we know where the location um not yet
but we'll get the venue name that's
gonna be me you our boy riley's gonna be
playing this that'd be so difficult a
sick invite yeah
okay
you'd that'd be sick if you came by man
yeah
yeah um
uh shout out to my tattoo artist johnny
from mojave creative in santa monica
he's going to give me another tattoo
with a
a folklore
korean tiger which i'm super excited
about but he i love his work it's
amazing so i just want to give him a
shout out
and then my obviously my stuff here it's
just chinsuyi on everything
oh yeah nick uh another podcast show is
the other podcast i do with two guys i
tell a crazy story about hunting
homeless in uh
san francisco
[ __ ] to rescue them
30k on instagram
y'all just got him sitting at 27.7 what
the freak nick yeah get him give him the
[ __ ] 30k i'm shocked by this actually
yeah
i don't post enough
just this week i started to post again
but uh i like to think everybody follow
nick hell yeah yeah he's a funny dude
good call i don't know great producer
and also
i just
need homie at 30k
yeah yeah uh that's it that's it cool
all right nice peace
[Music]
[Music]
you